foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Hills California please welcome the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences Janet yang
good morning everyone and welcome to the
Oscars nominations announcement it is so
exciting to be back live once again to
kick off the official countdown to the
95th Oscars on March 12th for nearly a
century now
the Oscars has been the most esteemed
celebration of movies in the world it is
a chance for us to showcase the very
best films of the past year and for
Global movie fans to come together as we
shine a spotlight on artists working on
both sides of the camera
every year nominees in most categories
are chosen by their peers actors
nominate actors film editors vote for
the best edited movies of the year and
so on but the final and most anticipated
Award Best Picture is chosen by the
entire Academy membership that's around
10 000 filmmakers and artists living and
working in over 80 countries and now to
present the nominees here are today's
hosts
2022 Oscar winner Riz Ahmed and the star
and executive producer of Megan Allison
Williams
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody we've been awake all night
getting ready for this moment
and we're so excited so honored so over
caffeinated to reveal the nominations
for the 95th Oscars good morning
everybody Riz I am so happy to be here
with you you've been nominated twice and
you won an Oscar last year so I just
wanted to know did you watch this both
of those times
um I did watch it yeah but I didn't wake
up to watch it and the reason for that
is I never really fell asleep in the
first place there was just a lot of
anticipation and I know there's a lot of
people who can't wait for us to get
started so without further Ado here are
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role
Angela Bassett in Black Panther wakanda
forever
Hong Chao in the whale
Kerry Condon in the Banshees of inner
sharing
Jamie Lee Curtis in everything
everywhere all at once
and Stephanie shu
and everything everywhere all at once
next are the nominees for achievement in
costume design
Babylon
black panther wakanda forever
Elvis
everything everywhere all at once
and Mrs Harris goes to Paris
where is given the extraordinary sound
design on your film sound of metal why
don't you take this next category well
here are the nominees for achievement in
sound
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
the Batman
Elvis
and top gun Maverick
next up here are the nominees for
achievement in music original score
All Quiet on the Western Front
Babylon yes
the Banshees of in a Sharon
everything everywhere all at once
and the fablemens
and now we have the first of the two
award categories that honor writers the
first is adapted screenplay
the nominees are
All Quiet on the Western Front
screenplay by Edward Berger Leslie
Patterson and Ian stokel
Glass Onion a Knives Out mystery written
by Ryan Johnson
living written by kazuo ishiguro
and top gun Maverick screenplay by Aaron
Kruger and Eric Warren singer and
Christopher macquarrie Story by Peter
Craig and Justin marks
and women talking
screenplay by Sarah Polly
and here are the nominees for original
screenplay
the Banshees of inner Sharon written by
Martin McDonough
everything everywhere all at once
written by Daniel Kwan and Daniel
shinert
the fablemans written by Steven
Spielberg and Tony Kushner
tar written by Todd field
and triangle of sadness written by
Reuben Osmond
now it's with great pleasure that I get
to announce this year's nominees for
best live-action short film
an Irish goodbye
ifalu
Le pupila
night ride
and the red suitcase
I'm now the nominees for best animated
short film
the boy the mole The Fox and the horse
the flying sailor
ice merchants
my year of dicks
[Applause]
and an ostrich told me the world is fake
and I think I believe it
thank you
no comment here are the nominees for
performance by an actor in a supporting
role
Brendan Gleason in the Banshees of Anna
Sharon
Brian Tyree Henry and Causeway
Judd Hirsch in the fablemans
Barry Keogan in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
and Ki Hui Kwan in everything everywhere
all at once
Riz this is a delight I don't want this
to end I have to say it's much easier
working with you than Megan she is
tricky yeah
she's not around is she
you promised me that she wouldn't be
around yeah
no we should be good we're good okay
cool uh anyway we'll be right back
because in just a few minutes we've got
more nominee announcements coming up
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back live from the Academy's
headquarters in Beverly Hills where Riz
and I are revealing the nominees for the
95th Oscars now earlier we announced
nine categories coming up now at the
Final 14 including best picture
here are the nominees for achievement in
music original song
Applause from Tell It Like a Woman
hold my hand from Top Gun Maverick
lift me up from Black Panther wakanda
forever
not to not to from RR
and this is a life from everything
everywhere all at once
things
now next up the nominees for best
documentary feature film
all that breathes
all the Beauty and the bloodshed
fire of love
a house made of splinters
and navalny
and here are the nominees for best
documentary short film
the elephant Whisperers
haul out
how do you measure a year
the Martha Mitchell effect
and stranger at the gate
[Applause]
hear the nominees for best International
feature film
All Quiet on the Western Front Germany
Argentina 1985 Argentina
close Belgium
Poland
and the quiet girl Ireland
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film
Guillermo del Toros Pinocchio
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
thank you
Puss in Boots the last book
the Sea Beast
and turning red
here are the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hair styling
All Quiet on the Western Front
the Batman
black panther wakanda forever
Elvis
and the whale
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
production design
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
Babylon
Elvis
and the Fable ones
the nominees for achievement in film
editing are
the Banshees of inner Sharon
Elvis
everything everywhere all at once
tar
and top gun Maverick
next up the nominees for achievement in
cinematography
All Quiet on the Western Front
it's Chronicle and a handful of troops
Elvis
Empire of light
and tar
and now achievement in visual effects
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
the Batman
black panther wakanda forever
and top gun Maverick
it's time for our final four Awards
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Austin Butler and Elvis
Colin Farrell in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
Brendan Fraser in the whale
Paul meskel and after sun
and Bill Nye in living
thank you
and now the five nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Kate Blanchett in tar
Anna De armas
Andrea reisborough into Leslie
Michelle Williams in the fablemans
and Michelle yo in everything everywhere
thank you
just two categories Remain the first is
achievement in directing and the
nominees are
Martin McDonough the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Daniel Kwan and Daniel sheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Steven Spielberg the fablemans
Todd field tar
and Reuben usland triangle of sadness
now the final category
here are the ten nominees for best
motion picture of the year
All Quiet on the Western Front mounted
Blue Notes producer
Avatar the way of water James Cameron
and John Landau producers
the Banshees of inner Sharon Graham
Broadbent Pete Charmin and Martin
McDonough producers
Elvis baslerman Catherine Martin Gail
Berman Patrick McCormick and Skyler
Weiss producers
everything everywhere all at once Daniel
Kwan Daniel sheinert and Jonathan Wong
producers
[Applause]
the fablemans Christy mccosko Krieger
Steven Spielberg and Tony Kushner
producers
tar Todd field Alexander milshon and
Scott Lambert producers
top gun Maverick Tom Cruise Christopher
Macquarie David Ellison and Jerry
Bruckheimer producers
triangle of sadness Eric hemendorf and
philippec producers
and women talking
Deedee Gardner Jeremy Kleiner and
Francis McDormand producers
this was such an honor and huge
congratulations to all the nominees
I hope you really soak up this moment
and enjoy everything that lies ahead and
in case you didn't know Saturday
February 11th is global movie day so go
see the nominated movies at your local
theater tell them we sent you and be
better prepared for your Oscar pool and
thank you for joining us and be sure to
watch the 95th Oscars live with host
Jimmy Kimmel Sunday March 12th foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the most magical place in the world
you start making movies
it'll break your mother's heart
this is larger than any of us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign